so welcome everyone I'm timid Henry I
direct programs here at the Rubin Museum
of Art where we do our best to channel
some of the great wisdom traditions of
the high Himalayas and offer them to you
here in the 21st century in the
foothills of Chelsea so what are we
exploring tonight this is a series
called brainwave where we pair mind
scientists with people from other walks
of life to attempt to figure out what
this thing we think of as reality
actually is and maybe it never is but
we're going to find that out tonight no
question so this whole series is based
on the idea of perception and those of
you who have visited the Tibetan
Buddhist shrine room will know that the
shrine room is calibrated and devised as
a sensory experience you not only seen
things you smell the the fragrance in
the air are you allowed to touch the
beads just don't touch the really
precious objects if you don't mind and
and you really just take the whole thing
in you can hear the sounds and you also
realize how limited you are in terms of
your perception because you're not
actually taking everything in in Tibetan
Buddhism there are not five senses there
are six senses and the sixth sense is
consciousness the one that processes the
input from the so-called outside world
now what has time got to do with that
because that's what we're going to try
and explore today the notion of where
the time is something that is relative
or that is fixed or that there is a
future or there isn't and some may think
given our present situation that there
is no future but hey let's take courage
and explore the nature of time both past
present and everything in between and
maybe these are just words
and they don't actually mean very much
well funnily enough Dean Van Amato who
is here from UCLA his professor
neurobiology and psychology there has
just brought out this new book called
your brain is a time machine the
neuroscience of physics and time oh
sorry the you know science and physics
of time but this is the way he starts
his book intriguing me right at the very
beginning he launches him in a chapter
called flavors of time time person year
way day five words what are the words in
the above list have in common he asks
anybody want adventure my will start you
know any takers
religion time person year way day I'm
going to cut to the chase this is what
Dean writes one would certainly be
forgiven for not recognizing them as the
five most commonly used nouns in the
English language that the word time sits
atop the list along with two others at a
units of time is a consequence of the
overwhelming importance time plays in
our lives we were not asking for the
time we are speaking of saving time
killing time serving time keeping time
not having time tracking time bed time
timeouts buying time good times
time travel over time free time and my
personal favorite lunch time
so this is about the perception of time
to the use of the vehicle that we use
most commonly to communicate with one
another which is language but our
language you can see it sort of runs
from left to right in lines it's linear
it does that how many people saw Danny
for Evelyn Irv's film arrival a handful
of you right how many people have read
Ted shams stories of your life you've
fewer that's interesting so the rest of
you on a real mystery tour tonight
congratulations thanks for coming out
not knowing what you are in for let me
just describe end in a chance book
stories of the life which which is the
basis for this film arrival these these
creatures beings from another world
another spatial realm arrived on earth
and they try and communicate with
somebody who is an expert in languages
and they use logograms and in the film
the logograms are depicted you don't see
them depicted and obviously in and
described in that sense of in Ted story
but they're depicted as
multi-dimensional expressions you can
read them in three and possibly the clue
is four dimensions so these hat the pods
communicate in this way that's their
language so the question we're going to
ask first is does the language dictate
the perception of time because they have
two pods use the language to instill in
the translator an understanding of
multiple futures that are lived
currently
and that exquisite notion is what I'll
leave you with because you're going to
discover more we're so delighted to have
Ted Chang here those of you don't know
he's a science fiction writer but over
the course of the last 25 years with his
stories he's won so many awards
including I just like reading these
awards out it's not like Tony's
Velasquez is way cooler for nebulas he's
got four Hugo's for locus ah's and the
John W Campbell award for best new
writer well he's no longer new right he
is so well established now and much
beloved please welcome Ted Chiang and
dr. Dean wanna monitor
[Applause]
hi dad hi bean so taking the cue from
Tim maybe we could start off talking a
bit about language and time they think
this is something that you certainly
delve in in story of your life and I
touch upon but to do this maybe it would
be helpful to set up the stage for the
discussion to talk about two terms that
I think will be helpful and we're
talking about time in terms of how
philosophers often view the two theories
of what time may or may not be mister
terms are present ISM which only the
present is real the past was real the
future some configuration or some
version of the future will be real but
only the present is feel another is
eternalism in which the past present and
future are all equally real and now is
just an arbitrary point or arbitrary
moment in time as arbitrary as here so
now it's time is here is this thing now
your your story certainly sort of
implicitly embraces the notion of
eternal ism where the past present
future are all equally real but language
is inherently present asti's word
conjugations which are normally related
based or reference to the present and so
in reading your book there's some
sentences that they have to read twice
because it's hard to talk about this
with with language so you have sentences
like I remember when you will be
one-year-old or I remember when what you
will say when you're 12 and so it's hard
to process a sentence because language
wasn't really set up to talk about an
eternal astir you can you maybe
elaborate a bit on your view of how
language constrained you or or talked a
bit about time and language okay well I
go
I don't think there's any any language
that would really help us understand
eternalism you know at a visceral level
the idea of a journalism that the future
and the past are just as real as the
present you know that is I think people
people who hold to journalism can only
do so in an intellectual abstract
fashion I don't I don't I don't know
that we are capable of really feeling it
living it and yeah I I don't think I
don't think human consciousness is
capable of really embracing paternalism
and I think young all language is going
to just reflect the fact that yeah we
are we we live in the present I think
that it it well I guess I would you know
it's interesting that so like animals
who lack language I think we would say
you know they they only live they only
have knowledge of the present humans
perhaps as a result well maybe not as a
result but humans have language and we
have knowledge of the past as being
something different
the futures being something different
than the present and you know that is
something that animals animal animals do
not have but the sum and the different
ways that our language can sort of
reflect our awareness of the past in the
future you know I think different
languages do offer different
perspectives on that
and that is one of the ideas that I was
trying to explore in the story and I'm
reminded of in terms of so journalism
naturally enables the concept of time
travel no your your story doesn't
necessarily engage time travel directly
but I'm reminded in reading your book I
was reminded one of my favorite lines
from Douglas Adams Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy which in the distant future
they finally figure out how to do time
travel and but they had to prohibit it
not because of the paradoxes or causal
on paradoxes that created in terms of
potentially going back and committing
grandpa side for example but because
verb conjugation was way too complicated
and I think I think this this is
something that that you come up against
in terms of a verb conjugation becomes
very wildly complicated in terms of
expressing ideas that may happen in the
future but you can avoid by jumping back
and future or jump further in the past
but what's your view of mean obviously
you wrote a piece of fiction but on a
more serious note do you what's your
view do you think only the present is
real do you think the universe is
eternal list in which the past present
and future are equally real I mean
nobody knows the answer but what's your
view well I guess I am persuaded by the
arguments from physics in favor of
journalism or yes physically in paper
the block universe view Einstein's
relativity makes a case which I I find
pretty persuasive that that the the
future is as real as the past or the
present and that like that it's not one
that yo I can really inhabit but at an
intellectual level
I understand the argument that
relatively makes an eye I buy into it
and so I have yeah I do agree with that
we live in an eternal universe which is
sort of a standard view in physics so
the standard view in physics is this
notion that in part given a lot by
relativity both special and general
relativity of this notion that because
time is relative you end up with the
situation in which there's no absolute
simultaneity and if so an events near
and far it doesn't make sense to ask if
their simultaneous occurring
simultaneous because it's relative to
your perspective to your speed or so
forth so this ends up leading into this
block universe that Ted mentioned or the
Eternals view in which everything has
already been laid out but this creates a
severe clash with our intuition it's
sort of mocks our intuition of of time
passing of time flowing in which the
past isn't accessible it's gone we
certainly feel that way and and the
future is wide open
yet undetermined so there's this clash
between the physics of time and I would
say the neuroscience of time so would
you do you feel that this is an illusion
that our sense that time is flowing and
the idea here is that if everything is
already laid out in the block universe
time wouldn't really flow as much as it
would just exist right so this flow of
time that's a very salient experience
for us humans the idea there and
physicists have struggled Ernest would
be would be illusory in some sense do
you see this clash or does that bother
you
well I suppose depends on what we mean
exactly by illusion I mean I think if
physics does not say that we ought to be
able to remember the future
[Music]
and actually there's there are I mean
there's some work now I'm like actually
why really makes sense that you we can
only remember in one direction and not
the other but so in the sense that
there's there should be there's no
expectation that we ought to be able to
remember the future so it's not so much
an illusion that you know we don't
experience eternalism it is it is a
function of you know just the way either
our brains work or or perhaps the way
any information system can can work not
specifically our brains but at anything
well so this is just to explain a little
bit about what I'm talking about there
the question of why is it that we can
remember the past but not the future
there you know and and you know what
even is the difference between the past
and the future from a physics standpoint
there there is a an arrow of time that
is a result of thermodynamics of
increasing entropy that if we say the
universe started with the Big Bang that
was stated extremely low entropy and if
the universe ends in something like the
heat death that's a state of extremely
high entropy and there is a steady
increase in entropy from one end to the
other of the of the block universe so
why is it that we feel that we are you
know moving in one direction as opposed
to moving in the other direction there
is a theory of that memory bigness based
on some some work on information theory
and interaction with thermodynamics that
recording
in any information and then serve
reading recorded information that would
inevitably involve an increase in
entropy if this theory is correct that
means any event that is recorded would
have to be closer to the low entropy end
of the block universe then then the time
of recording so that means any any
memory will have to be of the lower
entropy direction and that is what we
know that's what we call the past and so
if this if this theory is correct it
would be impossible to remember the
future because that would mean that
would require accurate recordings of a
higher entropy state and that it seems
like that may be physically impossible
so so in that it so that if that is true
then any information system our
including our brains you know could only
contain accurate information about one
direction which is you know be lower
entropy direction and so and we so we
call that the past and so our as you'll
we record more information yo the you
know we sort of perceive that as our
consciousness moving through time the
this notion of asymmetry of time in
which if we live in internalist universe
it should be bi-directional and what
Ed's referring to is well why don't we
quote remember the future as in Louisan
and your story would say i remember when
this will happen along those lines but i
think it's a very profound scientific
question I think physics and
neuroscience have to collaborate a bit
more here ultimately so the standard
view in physics because in large part
because of relativity and also because
the fundamental laws of physics don't
seem to have any special meaning for the
present
there's the present seem to be as
arbitrary as I said before as the here
so if that's the case and then time
doesn't really flow we have to decide if
we want to interpret our sense of the
flow of time as an objective observation
about the universe it certainly seems
like time is flowing it certainly seems
like the present is evolving into the
future it certainly seems like the
actions I choose to make now affect the
future but is that and then should we
take that as an empirical observation
about the universe one that which then
physics has to explain or is it just a
trick of the mind of one sort of the
other somehow an illusion of
consciousness and then there are science
has to explain that but I think we
should clarify here and say that even
though the sort of standard view in
physics is tends towards eternal ism
there's certainly no evidence of that
there's nothing anybody would call an
empirical proof that the past present
and future are equally real I think
depending on who you ask and I think the
different physicists will give you
different answers but I think it in my
view it's a it's better expressed as
it's the simplest using Occam's razor
it's the simplest interpretation of
relativity but other aspects of physics
don't necessarily mesh with that
including quantum mechanics has a
different treatment of time so it gets a
bit complicated but in terms of
consciousness and whether consciousness
is compatible I think our Iranian
position of determinism in free will and
what consciousness is so consciousness
is probably not this linear narrative
that we use in language about the
passage of time we seems to be involving
a to B to C to D but consciousness seems
to maybe emerge in fits in bursts and an
example from language that I would use
to express the
so it's a bit of a hard concept to wrap
your head around but I'm going to say
two sentences and we can sort of follow
in your brain how you interpret those
two sentences so the first one is the
mousepad was beside the computer second
sentence the mouse was hungry so the
meaning of the word Mouse there is very
different in both cases one's a living
animal one's a computer device but you
can only interpret the meaning of that
word Mouse by the words that came after
the mouse pad or the mouse was hungry
so if conscience was a linear flow of
the events taking place I know that that
would be very hard to explain right it
doesn't see I think most people probably
don't feel that they understood the word
Mouse and then we went back and edited
it but it's probably sort of your brain
waited to the appropriate moment for
your unconscious brain to feed in a
conscious narrative - to your mind so I
think to resolve these type of issues to
resolve this question of whether
consciousness as we know it is
compatible with physics or that
interpretation of physics I should say I
think it will be interesting and in in
one of the few fields of science where I
think neuroscience and physics have to
collaborate more at least in in my view
well I guess I feel like you know that
like the question that you bring up
about you know our making sense of these
sentences yeah I guess I feel like you
know that's that's certainly a question
for cognitive science and neuroscience
and linguistics I'm not sure it's a much
a question for physics I you know I'm I
agree that it does it does indicate that
our our that our conscious perception
and as we you know make sense of
language that is something that is sort
of
constructed and it is not immediate we
are probably sort of lagging behind our
sensory input by some young some some
delay so yeah so we're hearing the words
and but yeah we're not really making
sense of them
we're not constructing you know making a
narrative out of that for like I'd like
another second or so right so that gives
us time to know our sentences I agree
and but again yeah I guess I feel like
yeah I'm not sure that there's a physics
that I don't know that something that
physicists need to well I think I think
the the intersection is in the decision
of whether we should interpret our
conscious perception or the subjective
feeling of the flow of time as empirical
evidence amount so take another aspect
of human cognition that people interpret
as an illusion so our perception of
color so color is an illusion in the
sense that it's created by the mind
because color doesn't exist in physics
what exists is wavelength of
electromagnetic radiation so color is
the brains if you will interpretation of
the wavelength of electromagnetic
radiation and it's subject to all sorts
of illusions but it has an evolutionary
value so color is in a sense an illusion
but it correlates very tightly with the
physical property with something that's
very relevant in physics and why does it
correlate well because it's incredibly
adaptive to know the color of things to
know if that snake is poisonous or not
or food is ripe or not it's very
adaptive to know the color so evolution
tells us that a lot of what we feel and
experience has an evolutionary
underpinning now if we live in a
journalist world in which time doesn't
really flow but it's sort of more static
then we have to I think also just the
question of well what would be its
evolutionary value
and if we have a sensation that has no
Cortlandt in physics so I think that the
the need for the interaction is to come
together with this interpretation should
we accept a terminal ism as an
interpretation or as a fact and then if
we should take our subjective sense of
the passage of time as an empirical
absolutely what constitutes an empirical
observation about the world does our
sensical time count and this is a
empirical observation that has to be
accounted for by physics or not so and
that's what I mean by the intersection
so you're right in the fluence that are
many of these questions are about
cognitive neuroscience but to determine
if we should accept this or not as a
physical observation I think is where
the intercommunication would be a bit
more beneficial but time will tell yeah
I could be wrong well yeah so when you
say like okay what is the adaptive
advantage of you're perceiving
time passes if it doesn't flow yes yes
if that if there's no actual physical
correlation after that yes yeah well I
guess one one question to ask would be
you know what is the alternative given
that so it like if this theory about
memory yeah inevitably being tied to an
increase in entropy so you know so no
information system can know the future
can have accurate recordings of the
future so that means any information
system could only sort of create
information about what we call the past
and so what other what is the
alternative that yellow such an
information system develops some kind of
subjective experience you know what
would that what would what is if that
theory is correct I think it's a good
point if that theory implicitly imposes
any symmetry on memory
I think that could go a long way towards
explaining this clash but that by the
way is a beautiful example of
interaction between physics and
neuroscience right because you're
talking about well maybe the entropy
explains something at the lesson at the
neural level that but the whole idea of
it I mean this is as we all know all of
us are speculative including this and in
this theory but this is you know it's
possible we won't ever be able to answer
these questions but on a related issue
is because this question of how the
brain just tells time to begin with
right so we have these notions of the
brain whether or not it perceives time
as flowing or subjective the brain
certainly tells time and everybody does
this and in relation to language again
it's very interesting that our abilities
that you mentioned earlier on is that
animals don't seem to be able to have a
grasp of the past present and future as
much as humans that they're more present
base and I tend to agree with that
there's a debate about the degree to
which that's true or not but the
question is is well how did humans come
to acquire that ability and much of that
some people believe that it's by
metaphors or understanding space so
people some people believe that our
human uniquely human ability to
understand time relies in part on our
ability to understand space so the
neural circuits responsible for
understanding space were co-opted to
understand time and that this explains
why we in language and most languages
use spatial metaphors to talk about time
so it was a very long day in hindsight
that was a bad idea or you're thinking I
hope this talk in shortly so this notion
that we use spatial metaphors is again
in naturally spatial eyes as time so the
spatialization of time whether it's true
in the universe or not is a very natural
phenomenon and a lot of a couple of
investigators study this with very
common example that I'll ask the
audience
next Wednesday's meeting has been moved
forward two days so who thinks the
meeting is now on Monday okay who thinks
the meeting is now on Friday okay we
have a majority of people who are
egocentric with time so what that means
is that if you think the means that the
meeting is on Friday that sort of
implies you have this sense that you're
moving through time and since you're
moving Monday Tuesday Wednesday moving
it forward it end up on Friday if on the
other hand your static and time is
moving towards you those of you who
raised your hand on Monday that would
imply a more time centric where time is
coming towards you and interestingly
enough this egocentric versus time
perspective time moving perspective is
not fixed it's actually various varies
according to what you were doing but
it's one of the many examples of how in
language we use and spatial metaphors
and another one that comes up is this
issue of the future being forward right
yeah yeah oh so we were talking a little
bit about this before that we in in
English and I think all European
cultures we all think of the future as
being ahead of us you know that the past
is behind us and that is it seems to be
baked into most of most languages but it
is not a universal idea the Aymara of
Central America they think of the future
as being behind them and the past as
being in front of them and and this is
really you know the first time you hear
it this seems very counterintuitive to
most of us but but you know there is a
sense in which it makes a lot of sense
in that you'll we know the past and so
we can see the past
and so the future is hidden to us so in
that regard it makes sense that the
future being hidden from us should be
behind us and the past you know that is
known to us should be in front of us and
then and then with regard to the
question of like yeah does that mean I'm
walking backwards
and you know like maybe if you have if
you have the idea of yo you what that
sort of this Yegor centric view that you
are walking through time but you know it
could be that yeah time is you are
standing and time and sort of flowing
around you and so you know more and more
of time is coming into view for you but
and but you know that definitely
requires a sort of you know cognitive
shift for for most people I mean most
Western Westerners and as another
example there this cognitive scientist
Raphael no new leadership
he did he did work with the youth know
people in Papua New Guinea and he he
found that they seem to believe that
based on the way that they talk in the
way they gesture that the future is
uphill and the past is downhill and and
it's you know an interesting thing they
live in an extremely hilly area so
there's basically no flat flat land
anywhere you know everything is sloped
but but yeah they to some extent they
think of the future as upslope and the
past is downslope and so the odd thing
about that is that that is not dependent
on you know where you where you're
facing you know for both our version of
time and time our aversion of time they
are egocentric yes they're dependent on
you know yes every direction I'm facing
but this
if no way of cooking time it is
it's geocentric its terrain centric so
yo in some way yell it is independent of
the way that you yourself are positioned
and you know I I don't think there's any
you know I don't think there's enough
data on me like how fully this yo
affects you know their conversations you
know like just what hopefully does it
infiltrate every aspect of their life
but it's an interesting thing to think
about and I think that it's hard to
think about time there's a paradox that
I've always struggled with and that we
intend to specialize time and I think
this influences how we think about time
and I think this this leads some people
to more readily experiece eternalism and
I raised the possibility that physicists
do to then turn spatialization of time
in not only the equations but in
thinking about it we write the T axis on
graphs as this inherent specialization
of time as your brain becoming more and
more familiar with it and I I worry that
that creates a bit of a bias and
interpretation in which we accept the
the standard expectation a bit too
strongly without enough empirical
evidence which as I said is still
lacking now if this is the natural
interpretation to think about time in
the spatial dimension what's puzzling to
me is if you go through the literature
history is how long it took on writers
to come up with a notion time travel
it's really I mean now it's everywhere
where you can't turn your damn TV on
without seeing a show on TV about time
travel right but you know Shakespeare
who who had predicted every Hollywood
ever skipped time travel right and you
look through historical writing and
maybe there's a few exceptions but until
the very late nineteen eighteen hundred
very late eighteen hundreds which was
coincidentally enough right around where
Einstein was delving into special
relativity and not only Einstein others
were working on the problem why is it do
you think that something that's so
common in universal now in terms of
stories about time travel was absent
largely from the literature for so long
okay so I do have a theory up about this
fantastic
ok so because you know it it definitely
had struck me as odd that a lot of sort
of things that we associate with
fantastic stories about like traveling
to distant places you know they are
present in ancient myth in some version
you know people being transported to
great distances but with yet but yes
time travel stories do not exist in any
ancient ancient mythology however there
is I think there is some sort of analog
to time travel stories which do exist in
ancient mythology and that is stories
about prophecy because if you think
about stories of prophecy as information
traveling back in time then there this
is the since the this is ancient version
of time-travel stories and and I think
for me the I think the the big
difference between these are pre modern
and modern stories and why you know the
role that time plays and the role that
you know the president's time travel in
modern stories I think that actually has
to do with an increasing importance in
the increasing popularity and the idea
of free will because because well you
know the
the consistent thing in any mythological
story that features prophecy is the
prophecy always comes true something you
you get some information about what will
happen the characters they do their best
to avoid it and all they accomplish is
bringing it about so you know all of
these stories they reinforce the idea of
fate that your destiny is is fixed but
you cannot change your fate I think in
the modern age the idea of free will the
idea that people had agency that people
you know your future was not fixed that
I mean your destiny was not was not
decided that became more popular I think
even like just the term free will you
know I think I think may only appear in
like 1816 and and for me the for me the
first crucial story about time travel is
not HD wells time machine which is often
cited but I think um it's actually
Charles Dickens's Christmas Carol
because because there's the scene where
Scrooge is visited by the ghost of
Christmas yet to come and he is sown a
vision of his funeral and he he dies
unmourned and and Scrooge asks the other
spirit of Christmas yet to come
so spirit is this what will be or is
this what may be and see right there he
is asking do I have free will yell do I
have agency you know can you know if is
my fate decided or is my fate open to me
and that is the first story because then
he you know whether it was a dream or
not
he you know but I mean yeah he goes he
immediately sets about to change his
face to you make sure that what he saw
does not come to pass that it I think
it's the first story in you know in
history where you know he got you know
essentially a prophecy and he was able
to avoid it
so and you know I think that that idea
that that notion of agency that the
future you know is not is not determined
that your fate is not already decided I
think that is sort of that is what makes
time travel stories possible because
without that notion
you know if it's you know time travel
stories in which you can't change
anything that yield those are not
stories that's fun yeah you're like that
that those those yeah that that's not
that's not what now we think up for a
time travel story so it's sort of I
think the unspoken assumption of time
travel stories is that you can change
right but there's an irony in that right
because eternalism doesn't necessarily
imply you can change anything and this
raises the quiz whoa in in the
literature people sort of have this view
of stories that are consistent or
compatible or causally incompatible and
Ted story in the book is the perfect
story of a compatible there's no
paradoxes that are created in which or
causal links that are broken in which
you go back and component and commit
grandpa's on time is there but it's not
so much now in the movie it's a bit
different I don't know your
interpretation there if there's a causal
issue they're not but it raises this
issue of free will and can we change it
now I my view as an earth science is the
whole debate about free will is is
somewhat misguided in that free will a
lot of the problems in discussing free
well is really a question about that
defining people how do you define primo
as I think everybody well it's my
ability to choose
you know k but what does that mean your
computer program can choose something
does it have free will I think of the
neuroscientist my preferred view of free
will is simply that it's the feeling we
get it's the flavor of consciously debt
when our unconscious brain makes a
decision so in the same sense that if if
I was to step on Ted's toe and you would
feel pain that pain is a flavor of
consciousness that the conscious mind
generates in free will is flavor of
consciousness the mind generates when
the unconscious brain has made a
decision so whether you believe in this
deterministic view on universe in which
everything is laid out or not I view
freewill as a slightly different
question but in the context of time
travel of course it's the paradoxes
arrived are reason enough not to believe
it in my mind
hum well yeah I well a couple notes one
first one of the things about time
travel with regard to presentation
versus a journalism time travel stories
they sort of I think have to subscribe
to a blend of both presence is Amanda
journalism because they have to
subscribe to eternal ism in the idea
that the future in the past are there
places that you can actually go to but
they also have to subscribe to a present
ISM if they if as most time-travel
stories do they place priority on where
the time traveler is and that like oh
the future can be changed or the
listener hands yeah so if the if the
future can be changed then it is not it
is not real in the same sense that the
you know the epoch that I am in is real
so so they so any any time travel story
where it's possible to change things has
to subscribe to a kind of mixture enough
present is an eternal ism I agree in
part because language is sort of
inherently present and so these these
issues I think are fun but in terms of
the science is so is so so difficult
as again as a neuroscientist interesting
time one of the things that were
interested in is is a more less
philosophical question which is how the
brain tells time and I think a lot of
people when you talk about your sense of
time you're probably thinking of well
knowing the time of day or knowing how
long it is till lunchtime but what
you're doing right now is highly
time-dependent which is understanding
speech so you're paying attention
your brain is timing the pauses in my
speech we're using cues temporal cues
and positive and inflection to
communicate and the brain is incredibly
sophisticated time timing device and
temporal processing device and I'll give
you two examples of that so in language
for example if I say two sentences like
they gave her cat food or they gave her
cat food so there's two different
meanings there and based on pause and
another example is in music and music of
course doesn't make sense I think music
would be less enjoyable and internalist
universe right because it's already out
there it's sort of the change and so I
give an example and I think not may be a
good time if we can play the audio clip
and this audio clip will be of a song
and the challenge to you is to see if
you can recognize the song if it reminds
of anything else explain what it is
later I'll give you guys a clue and a
clue that whenever I give this to my
undergrads
they look at me with a blank face but
the name of the group is the Beatles and
and so this see if the song reminds you
of anything so can we play that please
[Music]
so does that remind you guys of any one
or two songs does anything anything
popping on your head
yo submarine anything very good anything
else I call blood any other Beatles song
so somebody said yesterday so the people
who sort of picked up on Yellow
Submarine we're paying attention to the
notes but the timing was totally of
yesterday so it was a hybrid song in
which we sort of crossed both of the
songs on the spatial and temporal and I
think this is a nice example first place
well how important time is to everything
we do and how and again this is the idea
that kind is really flowing but at the
same time how sophisticated the brain's
ability is to tell time on the scale of
tens of hundreds of milliseconds to a
few seconds and if you slow music down
or speed music up too much if you slow
speech down or slow speech up speed
speed up too much it ceases to be a
speech or music so this is very very
critical range or the Goldilocks amount
of time um Ted do you think we should
open up to questions at this point or is
there anything else you'd like to and I
mean um I'm sure we could probably go on
ill for hours but it probably is
probably appropriate to you know take
some questions now okay let's do that
then I think we shall do that and I
think Tim will be the referees on
moderation yes exactly so really short
questions because it is about time you
want to use time as efficiently as
possible
but that last musical is very helpful
because it allows me to prophesy or
least foretell the future that you might
take place in this theater on May the
25th when Shawn Colvin Rick Moody
Francine prose and David Duchovny will
convene and talk and play their favorite
Beatles tunes why well very simply aha
very simply we're exploring this world
of sound in the latter half of the year
what we're already doing so because
we've got this extraordinary little
recording booth on the 6th floor that
when you had a chance to transmit your
arm into the future along with thousands
and thousands of other visitors but
we're collecting all of your primordial
mantras and we're going to create a
soundtrack for this new exhibition in
June and based on your contributions so
we are one people who would like to ask
one question right in the back sir
Hey I think that this notion that the
ability to tell time is uniquely human
might be problematic because it known
that if an animal has to wait longer for
to receive the next unit of food then
they would more easily switch to another
food source or in in some cases you can
teach an animal to reproduce the time
interval or in there is even modern
theories that say that animals derive
the sense of confidence from elapsed
time so maybe the sentiment that you
guys express miss ruyan stab it no so
the notion wasn't that animals can't
tell time clearly we it's well
established fact for many reasons that
animals tell time not only animals by
the way plants tell time bacteria tell
time and that they have circadian
rhythms and examples you gave are
absolutely correct the notion that we
were referring to is that not that
animal cannot tell time but that it
cannot engage in what we call mental
time travel in to engage in long-term
thinking so animals of course squirrels
will store nuts birds will build nests
for the future my dog will bury a bone
but most of the day to suggest that
they're doing that necessarily and
thinking about the future but that's
more instinctual behavior so by the
argument for example that one thing a
signature of Homo sapiens what makes
Homo sapiens sapiens is our ability to
think about the long-term future so the
ability to carve a tool really is
something that you implicitly say you
know I'm going to I'm not doing this
because it's fun I'm going to do this
and use it in the future
one of the biggest inventions of
humankind was agriculture you know and
that's a hard one for animals right it's
the notion ok I'm going to obtain food
not by searching for it now but planting
the seed that's only going to bear fruit
in years so the notion the debate is
about timing animals can absolutely tell
time there's no doubt about that
but it's whether they can conceive about
and connect the dots between temporal
cause and effect spread out in time I
always wonder if human beings are the
only creatures to connect the dots
between sex and pregnancy right
I mean it's not something uniquely human
or I don't know if anybody knows me
answer let me know yeah with regard to
yeah the ability to plan for the future
yes I think there is only very scant
evidence that I think I read that they
they did observe some monkeys or Apes
that seemed to have some ability to like
gather some rocks in anticipation of an
event when they would need rocks to
throw but you know but yeah in general
yo in general field animals do not do
that you know you know if they you know
they only you know they will rely on
rocks being around them when they're in
the mood to throw them they will not lay
rocks
yo is no good rock yo cannot ignore that
and yeah so and and yet and that that is
sort of what I that that's what I was
talking about what about animals ability
to I mean humans being unique in our
ability to know the future think about
the future you know think about yeah
laying in supplies because yeah when
animals fatten up for the winter it's
not because they're thinking like well
we better we better prepare it's just
like you know there and there's some
instinct where they're like let's face
it there's some teenagers that can't
even do that right at me I should save
this for later
yeah yeah yeah would anybody like to
exercise free will and often question
yes sir you rise to the back and then
we'll come to you and then they come to
you yeah thank you
you mentioned time is flowing and I
think about water and streams and oceans
and water is recycled through
evaporation rain going back into the
ground do you think time can be recycled
[Music]
there's actually collection Binfield
memories in the back I guess I'm not
sure what we mean to say that time would
be recycled you can say time is some
people believe time is cyclic oh yeah I
was going to say that yeah there is ill
I mean the shirt of this idea of like
eternal recurrence that you know you're
going to live this life over and over
again but yeah in terms of you know
recycling time I guess I feel like that
particular metaphor yeah that that's an
aspect of the time flowing metaphor
which doesn't really apply in agreement
yeah and I think there are some
traditions certainly in the world that
the Ruben represents that might disagree
with you there is of course the musical
Groundhog Day opening on Broadway and of
course they're you know the protagonist
is condemned to repeat and recycle
existence but not consciously or only
gradually consciously until something
enters his consciousness to make an
register rather like Scrooge that I
should change my way and therefore
change my karmic expression and the
other one is of course the the Vedic
understanding that time is total
cyclical but it done such a massive arc
that we cannot contemplate the range of
it and there's this beautiful
illustration this concept in in Tibetan
Buddhism where the eons are described as
massive cubes that contain the list my
mute and we mentioned little animal
squirreling away so squirrel hairs tips
of squirrel layers stacked up in these
massive mile-high cubes
and each Yong there is already beyond
concept of what we can imagine in terms
of time flow each Eon is represented by
one of those tiny little squirrel hairs
so just imagine yourself removing one of
those tiny tips a squirrel has once
every Eon yeah you can't hang you but
that is the concept of time in in in
Buddhist philosophy it's it's just too
much who would like to yes your turn and
then we'll come to you go for it I was
really intrigued by the theory that you
mentioned about being able to store
things with lower and entropy and I was
wondering if you could tell me more
about where I could find out more about
that theory but also that I was trying
to think of examples of where you could
record things about the future and I
think the closest thing be able to make
prompt being able to use probability to
get pretty accurately about what the
future entails and do you think that is
the closest thing we can get to that's a
two-parter okay I'm afraid I don't have
a specific reference for you as to where
to find more information about this is
it Bennet the researchers at this
quantum information theory but oh that
might be that might be I mean I don't
think I read it from I don't think I
read Bennet specifically but it was in
the in the context of quantum
information and a theory so so that
might be a starting point okay so with
regards like probability as a way of
knowing the future and again we'll stick
with certain classical physics classical
physics and rap in the quantum physics
[Music]
you know that I guess
I think there are abilities at a
particular feature I think you know it
varies widely depending on the situation
there are some situations where systems
behave in very predictable fashion and
so there are systems where you can vary
you have a very high degree of
confidence of what its state will be in
you know at various points in the future
and so so it's not the case that you
know you never have any information
about the future but you know there are
also you know many many state systems
where we do not have good tools in which
in which there's strong mathematical
reasoning to guess that we will never
have good tools for predicting the
states of those systems embedment at any
editing point you know beyond the
immediate future so yeah I mean but I
think I I think your point about
probability is is the best we can do in
prediction and by the way my view is in
a lot of neuroscience views that's what
your brain in the prediction machine and
the ability of animals to predict what
their enemies or whether your
predator-prey nothing gives you an
evolutionary advantage like being able
to predict what's what's about to happen
so I think many people believe that one
of the main driving forces of brain
evolution was the advantages provided by
the degree to which animals can
obviously imperfectly predict what's
about to happen and if you look at a
clock you know to me a clock is a
prediction device you look at your
circadian clock you know we think that
is a clock that tells you what time it
is but it also prediction device telling
you this is when the Sun will rise this
is when you will be hungry so I think
chin in timing prediction and [ __ ] go
hand to hand when it comes to the brain
and surprises one word that we haven't
mentioned in terms of specifically human
behavior and thinking and emotions which
is the word imagination its imagination
being able to place yourself in a
different time space that allows you to
do the planning but it also allows you
to conceive of something that does not
yet exist in your current situation and
it's also imagination emotional
imagination is something that's key in
so the Buddhist thinking in terms of the
use of empathy so by putting yourself in
somebody else's shoes
you're better able to exercise that
fundamental essence of humanity which is
compassion and that's the key to your
changing you're sort of again this is
going to be reference to future your
your karmic implication so if you can go
about the world understanding how things
are connected you have much less need in
dependency on the future as such and
that's the way you actually subvert time
and its effect on you and that's also
counterintuitive but I leave that with
you we have another question yes sir but
I'd like to thoughts or for each of you
on whether you think the perception of
time that we have can be considered I
think the term is qualia that inevitable
ineffable personal experience like we
have of the color red do I know that my
experience of red is like yours is do
you think that's the same with time or
we're not sure about that
so I absolutely think that our
perception of the flow of time is a
quality of flavor of consciousness that
we can be dilated or contracted now I
think there's something a lot of people
ask well how is it that the subjective
sense of the flow of time can be
distorted so if you're engaged in a task
it seems to be going very quickly if
you're bored out of your mind it seems
to be going very slowly and this seems
as a mystery but I don't think it's as
much
I think the misdirection let me put it
that way I think the real mystery is how
we perceive time to begin with not how
it's distorted so I think the quality of
time whether we perceive it as accurate
matching external clock or prolonged or
contracted these are just parts of the
brains flexibility and assigning color
to one thing or a different color to
another thing so I think the real
mystery is how the brain ascribes a
sense of time independent of duration
and then the duration to what those
durations are I think are a bit
arbitrary and remember that this ability
to expand or contract if some is a
quality we have I can ask you to play a
song quickly in your head or slowly in
your head or do an action play play the
piano at a fast tempo slow tempo so the
brain has the ability in a one sense to
speed up its clock or just slow it down
I don't know I don't have a lot to add
to what Dean said in answer to your
question but I guess I wanted to just
follow up what Tim was saying about
imagination and our ability to imagine
things which we don't actually art are
not actually experiencing at the moment
and I think because this interesting
because this ties into what linguists
consider one of the defining
characteristics of language what
separates language human language from
animal communication and that is the
ability to refer to counterfactuals to
things that are not actually happening
here now when you know like when prairie
dogs when they or monkeys when they
warned each other about a predator you
know they're warning them about a
predator that they see they do not have
the ability to say talk about the idea
of predators that they don't actually
see they cannot you'll refer to
something but you know like yeah
let's let's talk about you know those
Panthers or whatever like they take it
they cannot engage in a conversation
about things which are not yes are in
their here and now when bees when bees
communicate about you and they you know
give very detailed information about
here you know here's yellow flowers to
get nectar you know at this distance as
in this direction but you know they had
no ability to you talk about like well
tomorrow there might be you know ill
nectar there or you know let's split
let's discuss you know like if we if we
have nectar two places what should we do
like yeah they cannot engage in any kind
of speculation or your reference to
things which are yo are not actually
happening and human the fact that humans
can do this you know it's obviously
essential in our ability to you know
plan about the future and it is
something that human language is is
unique in doing it gives us the
capability to refer to these things and
and again this is something that
linguists say as a site is one of the
things that distinguishes human language
from animal communication animals that
do seem to be able to communicate like
yeah chimpanzees and dolphins they ill
can communicate it's quite a bit of
information to each other but there's I
believe there's no evidence that they
are able to you know refer to things
that are counterfactual you know in the
way that humans can that we also not
only imagine the future but we imagine
the past so yeah maybe do you want to
talk a little bit about how memory is
sort of protective
and then to the interview time that
might be useful in terms of
understanding the brain mechanisms yeah
I think when we talk about memory we
happen to use the same word memory for a
computer memory or for human memory we
should probably have different words for
those things right because yes when we
talk it there might be a safer Wharf
element of the word memory there and how
we think about things but I think we
it's very misleading in the computer
when it stores memory it stores it very
isomorphic or faithfully to the external
world if it's a tape where we're taping
this right now it's it's a mapping of
exactly what's happening here but when
that's not what happens when we memorize
something you're not going to probably
go home and remember the color of my
shirt or Ted sure unless you're going to
line up later maybe but you're going to
remember that the context the facts so
human memory the goal of human memory
why do we have memory why do animals
have memory and this goes to the point
of prediction right the whole point of
memory is not to allow us to reminisce
about the good old times but it's to
help us prepare and predict for the
future the whole point of memory is
future-oriented and in order to do that
the brain doesn't store factual
information but highly processed
information about the gist the messages
that are presumably going to be relevant
so memory it's an interesting contrast
because memory is about the past but we
forget sometimes but it's really for the
future and I just want to gosh I know
you've got questions I just need to
throw in one thing before we go to the
final three questions which is again
this is an example in Tibetan Buddhism
and it's history that really illustrates
both past present and future in a very
interesting way so Parmesan bhava the
great Indian mystic came to the BET and
introduced Buddhism for the second and
essentially most effective time in the
ninth century and what he did ostensibly
was plant into the future these
spiritual time capsules in the form of
teachings that were then to be
discovered
by these cattle means Treasury reveals
who you can call them profits if you
will who in a future time would be able
to reveal Parmesan Baba's teachings to a
society that would be sophisticated
enough through the passage of time to be
able to receive these rather more
elaborate tantric teachings that were
evolutions of the initial Buddhist
precepts that were introduced into the
bed so here you have an example that's
incredibly politically and socially
savvy of suggesting that a belief system
is malleable through time and can adapt
itself just as we have to adapt
ourselves as societies to changing
configurations and that allowed the
lineage to be referenced back to the
past and get authority from parmesan
bhava and yet be virtually independent
as a as a means of discovery and
revelation and I think that would make
an uncannily interesting exhibition what
do you think if we do I I can't tell the
future of course I hate you know I don't
know whether it would ever happen but
let's see okay we've got time for three
more questions they have to be quick I
know we've got a class of hands are
there choose somebody Camilla and then
we'll take a quiz - wonder about how
time relates to pain perception because
if you have distress tolerance you have
pain and you say it's going to go away
some people have the capacity to endure
that time and some people do not and I
wondered if you couldn't speak to that I
think I am saying when you do this is
anecdotal story I don't know if it was
actually true said well as time is
relative and sitting cygnus the having
conversation relativity is that sitting
talking to a lovely woman for an hour
can feel like a mere five minutes but
sitting on a hot stove for five minutes
can feel like an hour so time certainly
obviously extends
or dilates our perception of time and
but how that happens there's theories
that you have a clock in your head you
have these circuits that tell time and
that there's certain hormones or
neuromodulators one of which is dopamine
that seems like it may be able to
accelerate or D accelerate the clock but
other than that we really don't know
that much about the neural mechanisms of
either pain for that matter of the
subjective part of pain we know about
the peripheral part of pain but we don't
understanding of how the brain generates
the subjective and ultimately is an
important part of pain
I don't think it's clear I don't think
we have a clear answer to that yet sorry
yes yes okay sir thank you for this
conversation we've talked a lot about
past and present no past and future
whether its forward backward uphill
downhill I've always had a problem with
the present because I felt that I'm
either living in the future or in the
past not too distant but you know when
you're walking on the sidewalk the foot
that's lifted has left fast and it's
about to step into the future and so I
came across this idea for life that I
wish to share which is that the presence
lies at the intersection of two eternity
advancing future now given all this
understanding are we sitting here in the
temple of Buddhism that puts stress on
living in the precious present and so my
question to you is how do you come to
that understanding of living in the
precious present when the present is
such a fleeting moment and step one
I don't together that you're you're so
William James one of the first
psychologists to talk about time
referred to the president as the
specious present the misleading present
and in part he's referring to this
notion that okay first place what's
present is really present because the
brain has all sorts of delays and
there's a delay for me my brain to
process what you just said so in a sense
we're certainly living slightly in the
past but the this notion of specious
presence and what the present is is very
tricky to grasp right because it's not
an instant it's this timely though and I
think this time window and this is
something we were sort of alluding to
earlier is some flexibility of what we
call the present in there when you're
processing sentences maybe you're going
to wait for the full sentence that I'm
saying to complete before your brain
generates a conscious perception
if I say something and I shouldn't even
say this backfire
I think that's against the law I don't
know if I yell out the word fire right I
think did I just break the law to him I
don't know if Emily no you did with such
subtlety okay nobody was particularly
liked though they are that's something
that you can cause this relatively quick
so the present there you you you have
shrunk that and processed that very
quickly so I think this notion of what
the present is is again in part in
physics and in neuroscience the
president is arbitrary in physics right
now the now is sort of arbitrary but in
in the conscious perception what we
define as the present is is some sort of
creation of the brain and last thing
I'll say about this is right now when
you're looking at me there's a delay
between the sound coming from my voice
and the sight of my lips moving those
things are really happening
asynchronously your eyes are seeing my
lips move before you're hearing the
voice well ignore the fact I don't know
where the speakers are but that delay
can be significant so if I was somebody
sitting in the back there that could
delay could easily be fifty five fifty
milliseconds or 100 milliseconds so
that's a significant delay yeah your
brain most of time is going to way to
adjust or tune those to create a nice
Pleasant narrative oh those things are
happening simultaneously but they're not
so this is another example of how the
present is relative as far as the brain
is concerned so I did something to add
to the present half presidency fellas
granted okay great
cuz I do so
I just want to okay if you don't already
know I would love to be able to say that
at the Rubin
we and in the present every second of
every day it's not true we're racing
around like the rest of you most of the
time however we do deliberately engage
and experience on Wednesday lunch times
at one o'clock for forty five minutes in
a mindfulness meditation which allows
you and it's a deliberate practice it's
a technique by which you register the
process of just breathing and then again
breathing is the first thing you did in
your life and there's going to be the
last thing you did in your life I'm
sorry if that comes as a shock but
that's so that this really basic tool
that we have to foster existence
breathing is what we focus on and that
allows you to get to the essence with
practice so I'm sorry I'll have to come
every week
one last question has got to be a good
one have you really got a good one
you've got a good one so we we spoke
earlier about how most language is
present ISM biased and but how in your
story and in the movie there's this idea
maybe in you know in turn ISM language
that let's use that view do we think
that both of your point of view is that
something that's actually possible and
if it is is it worthwhile
is it possible to to know the future
jingling bias or
I mean I guess I think would be possible
to have a language that doesn't have
quite the same biases that we that you
know English or most languages do I
whether that would actually change our
perception of time I yeah like it was
this thing before yeah I don't actually
believe it is possible for us to know
the future so so that the idea that it
appears in the story that this learning
an alien language enables the
protagonist to know the future that is I
I'm engaging a dramatic license for the
story
so you know so so yeah I don't believe
that yellow that a language can can do
what happens in the story but I do I
mean but yeah I definitely think that
yeah that you you language with a like a
very different way of representing time
could you know could shift our you know
a lot of our attitudes about time I yeah
I can't really be specific about you
know what what effects it would take but
I do feel that you know again some of
the examples that we mentioned about how
the way different languages treat time
and you know just the fact that our our
sense that you know that the future lies
ahead of us and our past lives behind us
you know that feels I think to most of
us that feels really deeply embedded in
us but but to realize that that is just
a cultural construct you know I think
that you'll I think that is valuable
because that indicates you know just how
profoundly culture can affect our
perception of ourselves and the world
around us and so I imagine that you know
it's sort of a reminder that we are you
know there were sort of humans are a
more flexible than we might initially
think and that you know in perhaps know
things that we think that we take for
granted as being inevitable Neil are
perhaps not inevitable that you know and
so that and that would apply to some
extent to our perceptions yeah I mean
to take a bit of a scientific license I
would say that you know in a way math is
allowing language and science of the
language in a sense that's what math and
the laws of physics do precisely that
is they take a more journalist view
correct or incorrectly but so in a sec
what most people mean by language but to
answer your question yeah I think
there's a ways to treat that which don't
necessarily necessarily imply it
journalism or presence is important take
the bias out so I think in a way math
and good laws of physics do a bit of
that and I'd like to suggest given the
place where we are is that there's
another form of communication that
doesn't necessarily and that allows you
to subvert a sense of time or linearity
of process and that is the act of
looking at a work of art it's not linear
and your eye will inevitably Rove over
it and find different things in
different connections which then
register different sense in
understanding yes admittedly through the
passage of time but it can always be
reach annulled and challenged in the
process of that particular communication
from artists to viewer and so I would
encourage everybody to go upstairs and
the galleries and check it out and see
what happens it could be kind of a cool
experience because we're open on Fridays
till 10:00 p.m. so you want to gauge in
that but I'm sure before you do you'll
stagger up those six flights of stairs
laden with both games book and heads
book if you don't have them already
they're happy to sign them for you right
outside in the Outlands right after this
program so we've been talking about
really the way time might be cyclical
and isn't it curious that the last
question was about language and time
which is a very first question this
I wonder whether that's meaningful but
thank you both so so much for we
grappling with a very very tricky thing
and we don't know what else to do here
at the women because we are fairly
limited in our expression however we do
have catalogs and plenty and given that
we've been talking about how time
transforms our perception of reality I
think the most fitting catalogs we can
present to the two of you is a really
first collection of the reuben art which
is called worlds of transformation
because it always will
Dean gonna run our congratulations on
your book it's really startlingly clear
[Applause]
and tension thank you for your
imagination
[Applause]